[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le 7-8
week-end sur tv 78 de votre émission qui
vous accompagnent dans cette fin de
semaine avec de l'actualité mais aussi
des idées de sorties loisirs voici le
programme de ce 22 octobre
depuis ce vendredi poissy a réduit la
vitesse de circulation en agglomération
elle passe de 50 à 30 km heure avec un
objectif avant tout de sécurité on en
parle avec marc lartigau conseiller
municipal délégué au tramway au plan
communal de circulation et de
stationnement
le bois soleil les jardins du bois
soleil les noms de ces nouvelles
structures dédiées aux seniors à bois
d'arcy il s'agit d'un ehpad et d'une
résidence qui vont permettre de doubler
la capacité actuellement de 65 résidents
et puis comme chaque vendredi la
sélection des idées de sorties pour le
week-end exposition photo à la villa
savoye de poissy cirque musical à
versailles le programme en deuxième
partie d'émission
et ce sera bien sûr en compagnie de
bixente mais rien son site et balmont
jour bixente engendré un gars à i-télé
le menu que vous nous avez concocté
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui comme vous avez
commencé à dire un programme complet sur
ce qui vous attend pour ces vacances du
coût de la toussaint parce que les
vacances débutent ce soir ce vendredi
soir ses vacances de la toussaint il se
sera tout à l'heure dans le sahtu ce
week-end
l actualité pour débuter cette visite
gouvernementale ce vendredi dans les
yvelines elisabeth moreno était à
châteaufort dans l'après midi sur le
site de safran la ministre déléguée à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
la diversité l'égalité des chances est
venu assister à la signature de la
charte de la diversité plus de 4100
entreprises y ont adhéré en france il
s'agit d'un texte d'engagement qui
existe depuis 2004 pour agir en faveur
de la diversité lutter contre les
discriminations un document proposé à la
signature des employeurs mais la
démarche reste volontariste le ministre
la ministre a pu échanger avec des
salariés du groupe lors d'une table
ronde avant de vous parler de la vitesse
qui baisse à poissy direction bois
d'arcy ou un nouvel établissement a été
inauguré un établissement pour les
personnes âgées c'est un ehpad et une
résidence seniors qui ont ouvert depuis
1er juillet avec 65 résidents
actuellement les deux structures compte
accueillir ces prochains ces prochains
mois de nouveaux occupants le reportage
de célia gars de son go et de clémence
robert
c'est officiel l'ehpad le bois soleil et
la résidence seniors les jardins du bois
soleil ont été inaugurés jeudi 21
octobre à bois d'arcy le directeur de
l'établissement très émue durant cette
cérémonie on va enfin le travail de
plusieurs années accomplies le projet a
pris plus de trois ans pour être
constitué essai avec la fusion des deux
établissements et la création du groupe
tenaris qui a permis effectivement de
faire venir cet établissement à la vie
et donc voilà c'est pour ça que tu es
émotions et c'est beaucoup de travail
cet établissement de haut standing
contre une maison de retraite
médicalisée qui peut accueillir jusqu'à
80 lits et une résidence pour seniors
composée de 30 appartements de deux
pièces des logements adaptés et
sécurisés pour les résidents ont trouvé
comment
s'aimer deux grands parents qui sont là
mes grands parents paternels et on a
choisi cet établissement là parce que
moi j'habite à côté du coin passant non
j'ai vu que c'était trop neuf et que ça
avait l'air bien du coup sont venus
visiter ce salon aura plus de nombreuses
animations sur le thème du cinéma était
organisée pour l'occasion comme de la
danse bollywood dans ces deux structures
une salle de sport un salon de coiffure
et d'esthétique et une salle de jeux
sont mises à disposition cet
établissement était un véritable besoin
pour la commune qui compte plus de 2000
seignard je revois des gens que je
voyais dans la dans la rue ou chez eux
il ya quelques années et que je retrouve
aujourd'hui maintenant dans cet ehpad
c'est à dire que c'est devenu un lieu
central de la circonscription les
artisiens souhaité reste à voir si c'est
une particularité de l'huile c'est assez
incroyable et c'est une chance qu'on a à
bois d'arcy près de 500 personnes ont
plus de 80 ans
paris montpellier mais aussi dans les
yvelines bougival villepreux et noisy le
roi l'ont déjà adoptée c'est au tour de
poissy et de passer en zone 30 la
municipalité à baisser la vitesse de
circulation de 50 à 30 km/heure et ce
dans toute la ville et pour en parler
marc lartigau est avec nous par
visioconférence bonjour
bonjour vous êtes conseil municipal de
poissy délégué au tramway au plan
communal de circulation et de
stationnement alors la mesure est entrée
en vigueur ce vendredi qu'elle est
premier bilan comment est accueillie
dans la ville de poissy
alors pour l'instant on n'a pas on n'a
pas de retour puisque le temps que tout
se met en place et tous les anciens
panneaux soient déposées ça va prendre
encore peut-être une petite journée mais
les volets
c'est à peu près bien accepté par la
population n'a pas encore de retour d
défavorable
bien sûr que les gens s'y habituent et
une fois que les habitants seront prises
et que n'y verront que la circulation
est rendue plus fluide par ce système
je pense que tout le monde a bien
assez à cette limitation à 38 rebelles
femmes on va parler dans un instant des
objectifs et la mesure concerne tous les
axes de la ville sauf de rares
exceptions même les routes
départementales 1 sont comprises dans ce
périmètre alors pourquoi ce choix
justement de concerner tous les axes de
la commune
alors au départ on avait dans notre
réflexion et notre envie politique
c'était de sécuriser sur tout le centre
ville qui est très fréquentée est en
fait en travaillant avec les services
techniques municipaux et les services
techniques de la communauté urbaine gps
et au on s'est aperçu qu'il y avait déjà
beaucoup de quartiers dans beaucoup de
nos quartiers il y avait des zones 30
des zones fin des zones de rencontre
il y avait des zones à 40 km heure de
tassin quand il y avait des axes à 70
donc tout ça ça commence à devenir un
peu lisible et quand on regarde quels
sont les retours d'expérience des autres
villes et les études qui ont été menées
ont ce qu'on s'aperçoit vraiment de la
diminution de l'accidentologie dans
l'est dans les communes donc on s'est
dit pour simplifier les choses
une autre ville s'y prête donc passons
de poissy à ville zone 30 idée reçue
aussi peut-être qu'il faut combattre
c'est pas parce qu'on réduit la vitesse
à 30 qu'on va traverser la ville enfin
le temps de traversée va pas se réduire
ces augmenté pardon considère a
considérablement ça c'est une idée reçue
non alors cmu-c une idée totalement
fausse parce que les études qui ont été
menées dans une ville à 50 km heure vous
traversé la ville en moyenne avec les
stops les feux rouges tous à tous les
incidents vous vous traverser la ville à
18 29 km heure
et quand vous passez à 30 km/heure une
villa à 30 km/heure vous êtes en moyenne
à 17,3 km heure c'est à dire vous dit
vous baisser la vitesse de 2 40% et en
fait vous diminuer la vitesse moyenne de
circulation de 10 % donc vous vous
allonger le temps de parcours de 10 %
donc un trajet nous vous faisions dix
minutes vous allez le faire en 11
minutes voilà donc c'est franchement en
termes de perte de temps c'est c'est
insignifiant ça vous l'avez dit ça
réduit également le risque d'accidents
parce que on imagine bien un premier
objectif de sécurité routière avec en
plus de drames qui sont survenus dans la
commune cette année le jeune nathan 12
en mars qui est décédé également joué le
bellec en juin qui était une agent de la
ville ces deux drames vous ont
définitivement convaincu de cette mesure
d'accélérer le processus
alors c'est pas c'est pas forcément ces
deux accidents qui nous ont qui nous ont
fait accéléré parce que la réflexion
était déjà menée
depuis même l'ancien mandat il faut il
faut savoir notre adjoint au cadre de
vie de leur mandat ils réfléchissaient
déjà donc c'est mais bon c'est sur ces
deux accidents malheureux ne faisait que
appuyer notre volonté et c'est vrai
qu'en termes d'accidentologie il faut
savoir que sur un accident
entre une voiture et un piéton à
30 km heure
seulement dans 10% des cas même si c'est
déjà trop l'accident sera mortel car à
50 km/heure à 85% des cas
ça sera mortel donc vous voyez
un peu
un peu les raisons de ces 30 km heure
parce qu'avant tout c'est la sécurité
derrière l'idée de sécurité il ya aussi
l'idée de favoriser de plus en plus les
mobilités douces plus de sécurité ça va
aussi impliquer que par exemple sur des
voies à 30 km heure on peut aussi faire
passer les vélos il y aussi le thé très
ce qui va arriver 1 l'année prochaine à
poissy donc il fallait aussi s'adapter
la ville est en train un peu de changer
de visage donc il faut aussi s'adapter
de ce point de vue là
où es-tu de toute affaire il faut
il faut bien prendre conscience que le
tout voiture en ville c'est terminé
c'est pas 4 à 6 et c'est d'une manière
générale c'est aussi une vo une volonté
des jeunes générations
maintenant
passée la ville à 30 km heure c est une
des la première étape est une étape
indispensable
pour le développement des mobilités
douces effectivement on a un tramway qui
arrivent de toute façon le long du
tramway la circulation et aurait été
mise à 30 km/heure donc sur l'agro une
grosse départementales qui traversent
notre ville
donc on anticipe un petit peu ce fait là
et effectivement on espère vraiment dans
un second temps pouvoir développer de
manière très sécurisée le
vélo et le et les piétons deux dernières
questions très rapide mark lartigau
combien de panneaux ont dû être
installés au niveau de la signalétique
pour pour ce passage au 30 km heure
quinze est-ce que ça a eu un coût pour
la ville du coup pour la ville non pour
gps et au un petit peu mais vous voyez
bon c'est par rapport aux bienfaits de
cette mesure
on n'a que quinze panneaux installés à
l'entrée de ville puisque on a 15 entrée
de ville le reste
des panneaux de limitation de vitesse va
être enlevé donc vous voyez le coût est
vraiment vraiment minime si on compte un
panneau qui coûte environ entre 250 300
euros et
et le temps d'installation des agents
honnêtement il ya des investissements
qui sont
beaucoup plus importants et dernière
chose pour justement vérifier que cette
vitesse et respecter ce que ça va
s'accompagner davantage de contrôler ce
que pour le moment va y avoir quand même
une petite période d'adaptation qu'on
peut comprendre aussi suite à la mise en
place de cette mesure oui bien sûr on a
travaillé avec notre police municipale
donc il va effectuer des contrôles mais
dans un premier temps qui vont des
contrôles pédagogique pour bien
expliquer que voici est devenue une
ville zone 30
donc ça va cette phase de pédagogie va
durer 1 2 mois et après ils continueront
les contrôles comme ils font
actuellement des contrôles de vitesse
régulier et là ça sera ça sera
malheureusement la sanction merci marqué
lartigau d'avoir été avec nous bah je
vous en prie mais je le rappelle
forcément ici pales de la ville de
poissy bonne fin de journée à vous
également délégué aux tramways et aux
plans communal de circulation et de
stationnement poissy 1 dans cette ville
où vous devez désormais rouler à une
vitesse maximale de 30 km/heure si vous
n'avez pas eu le temps de suivre
l'actualité cette semaine dans les
yvelines pas de panique justin brasier
nicolas landry vous résumer essentielle
et c'est en 78 secondes
aurore a soufflé sur une partie de la
france dont les yvelines la première
tempête automnale est passé dans le
département dans la nuit du mercredi 20
au jeudi 21 octobre des rafales de vent
enregistrées jusqu'à 120 km heure
résultat de nombreux foyers privés
d'électricité ou encore des arbres
déracinés le procès de la sextape de
mathieu valbuena s'est ouvert ce
mercredi au tribunal correctionnel de
versailles sur le banc des accusés cinq
personnes dont le footballeur karim
benzema représenté par ses avocats
un procès retransmis par l' agence
plaisir oise seces preuve lundi a débuté
la semaine nationale est là à l'origine
de l'événement l'association européenne
contre les leucodystrophies
un groupe de maladies génétiques
héréditaires qui s'attaque au système
nerveux au programme une dictée et
l'opération mets tes baskets dans le but
de récolter des dons jean castex s'est
rendu à saint germain en laye ce jeudi
21 octobre au programme du déplacement
la visite du quai des possibles
tiers-lieux saint germanois et des
échanges avec les bénéficiaires une
structure qui accompagne les personnes
éloignées de l'emploi et puis de la
vidéoprotection mutualisés pour les
communes et intercommunalités pourrait
voir le jour dans les yvelines un projet
du syndicat mixte interdépartemental
seine et yvelines numériques présenté ce
jeudi à la ferme du manet
objectif mettre en place des centres de
supervision sur le territoire
[Musique]
une précision qui nous est parvenu
concernant ce procès du chantage à la
sextape qui s'est tenu donc depuis
mercredi jusqu'à vendredi au tribunal de
versailles on apprend ce vendredi que le
jugement est mis en délibéré
est ce le 24 novembre le retour de votre
rubrique est légal checking à présent
pour vérifier ce que disent les acteurs
de l'actualité vincent courante du
collectif des surligneurs décrypte
aujourd'hui le secret de la confession
une question soulevée notamment après la
révélation du rapport sauvé sur les cas
de pédophilie dans l'église catholique
depuis la publication du rapport sauvé
sur les abus sexuels dans l'église la
confession est mise à l'index car des
prêtres n'aurait pas dénoncer des faits
dont ils ont eu connaissance dans le
secret de l'isoloir catholique le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
s'en est indigné et a cru bon de
rappeler à l'église qu'elle doit
dénoncer à la justice les faits de
pédocriminalité est ce vraiment un
devoir quelles sont les limites du
secret de la confession est bien le
secret de la confession est assimilé en
droit au secret professionnel et il est
protégé par le code pénal mais cette
interdiction de révéler des informations
couvertes par le secret professionnel
cède lorsque le prêtre a connaissance de
faits d'agression sexuelle sur mineur
dans un tel cas le code pénal prévoit
que révéler l'information aux autorités
et bien est une atteinte qui est
possible au secret professionnel qui
n'est pas cette atteinte pénalement
sanctionné mais est ce que cette faculté
de révéler une information pourrait être
considéré comme une obligation dans
certains cas seulement lorsque la
victime notamment de mauvais traitement
n'est pas en capacité de se défendre
elle même par exemple parce qu'elle est
mineure
c'est ce qu'a notamment jugé la cour
d'appel de lyon en 2020 dans la sphère
du cardinal barbarin dans tous les
autres cas ce qui est dit en confession
sur des faits de pédophilie nalité
peut-être ou non révélé aux autorités
par le prêtre cela relève comme le
disent les juristes de son option de
conscience
est la suite de ce sept huit week-ends
avec à présent la partie loisirs
et le retour tant attendu de bixente
mais rien senti steban en plateau pour
voir quel menu nous a concocté vous avez
vu j'ai réussi à le dire concocté cette
fois-ci bixente un mot pour le moins à
difficile non pas tant que ça en plus
alors on commence notre programme du
jour par un tour du côté de pression on
y était pour ce passage au 30 km heure
et on retourne à la villa savoye cette
fois ci a dit m photographiée l'éphémère
c'est une exposition pensée et mise en
scène par le photographe philippe
biancotto un habitué comme vous grégory
du festival de cannes et son tapis rouge
une découverte entre photographie et
monument architectural
reportage il fit fait la première kiev
de cette idée l'exclusion tour de la
glace de l'equilibre l'exposition ready
mels a ouvert ses portes à la villa
savoye à poissy des photos par l'artiste
et plasticien philippe biancotto ce qui
m'intéressait fait de la notion
d'équilibré la bave les de montrer que
la partie qui paraît la plus solide qui
est le métal peut s'effondrer si la
partie qui paraît la plus fragile la
glace n'est plus en faute fauteuils
talons aiguilles ont encore revolver des
objets mise en scène dans les
différentes pièces d'habitation de la
ville 1
[Musique]
on a investi tout le premier étage de la
villa qui est l étage d'habitation il y
à treize oeuvres c'est vraiment un
dialogue entre le lieu la photo en fait
la photo est vraiment le témoignage d'un
instant de glace là je voulais quelque
chose de vraiment sans fioritures qui
rentre directement d'une façon frontale
dans le dans le sujet qui qu'ils font en
quelques minutes pour ce pour certains
quoi philippe biancotto a été contacté
par le centre des monuments nationaux
pour effectuer un travail entre photos
et architecture habitué à la mode et aux
portraits de stars c'est son premier
travail avec un édifice ressent bien
l'éphémère puisqu'on voit la glace dans
les objets sont fait fondre et on se
demande si au fond toute cette
construction qui nous entoure ce
chef-d'oeuvre de le corbusier n'est pas
lui même destiné à disparaître comme ça
comme de la glace l'ars est transversale
donc on peut on l'a on fait un voyage
photographique avec avec l'exposition
qui démarre aujourd'hui et
l'icône le patrimoine qu'est la villa
savoye permet un dialogue entre la
photographie et le patrimoine qui est
tout à fait pertinent l'exposition en
déambulation à travers le monument pensé
par le corbusier est accessible jusqu'au
12 décembre
voilà pour ce voyage photographique du
côté de poids si on va parler à présent
sport bixente un sport qui nous plaît à
tous les deux c'est le football avec des
pépites à voir ce week-end à plaisir en
effet grégory si vous voulez du haut
niveau vous serez servis ce week-end
donc à plaisir samedi dimanche et le
challenge cup un tournoi qui rassemble
les jeunes du football français et
belges 24 clubs dont monaco l'om le psg
et même les équipes de bruges et anvers
en belgique seront présents finale ce
dimanche 24 octobre à 15h30 peut-être
que la future star du football y sera
qui sait et on espère qu'elle est
yvelinois cette future star du ballon
rond du côté de versailles le chapiteau
est monté niche est exactement de cory
l'association le cirque musical est en
pleine installation depuis hier dans la
rue du sénégal de versailles il ne reste
que les derniers préparatifs pour
accueillir les spectateurs du 23 au 27
octobre pour 10 représentations du
spectacle
padam padam padam padam plus tôt pour en
savoir plus voici une interview express
bienvenu ici sous un chapiteau mais sous
le chapiteau où va se jouer une comédie
musicale qui s'intitule padam padam à
partir de samedi jusqu'à mercredi 27
octobre
c'est une cocréation que nous avons
écrit nous même pendant les différents
confinement c'est une pièce autour de
edith piaf avec une dizaine de chansons
de chansons françaises de chansons aussi
en anglais
ce que vous allez pouvoir découvrir par
exemple dans ce spectacle il ya un
medley des valses avec plusieurs valse
des chansons écrites par edith piaf ou
de sons
des chansons contemporaines à son époque
et donc c'est nous avons chorégraphié
smedley tout en couleur et donc vous
allez pouvoir découvrir cette partie du
spectacle qui est vraiment magique
féerique sous ce chapiteau
on a beaucoup de place sous chapiteau on
a 300 places et on à dire aux
présentations ici à versailles donc si
on fait le calcul dix représentations
300 spectateurs on peut aller jusqu'à
3000 personnes
c'est quoi le monde du spectacle mais je
ne sais pas d'âme pas d'âme voile assez
vite dans le bon sens c'est à versailles
également qu'on reste est une fête
foraine qui s'ouvre en ce début des
vacances d'automne en effet la
traditionnelle fête foraine de
versailles ouvre ses portes ce samedi 23
octobre jusqu'au 14 novembre pour les
attractions c'est du classique manèges
tir à la carabine ou pêche aux canards
impossible d'être déçu vous irez sur
quelle attraction ou bixente moi je ne
sais jamais sûr comme décidé je sais
jamais mais j'ai décidé donc en général
fini à côté du stand de confiserie avec
une petite barbe à papa voilà le
gourmand bixente merrien santisteva en
tout cas ce soit sur le parking de
l'europe à verser de 14h à 20h du coup
pendant toute la durée des vacances
scolaires très important de préciser le
lieu effectivement alors en parlant des
vacances scolaires vous nous avez
concocté une petite sélection encore une
fois oui pendant ces deux semaines il y
aura de nombreux ateliers et animations
pour les enfants où vous fait découvrir
notre top 3
[Musique]
non
à
[Musique]
oh
quand même cette petite musique pour se
détendre et bien terminé la semaine
j'espère que vous êtes confortablement
installés pour suivre la fin de cette
émission cette ut week-end pour voir ce
qui se passe dans le week-end qui nous
concerne le 6 le week-end après week-end
à des 30 et 31 octobre on commence par
un voyage du côté de la celle saint
cloud avec une exposition même trois
expositions grégory ou la syrie est mise
à l'honneur car sa culture son histoire
son patrimoine ou encore la complexité
géopolitique de la région la plus
importante exposition
c'est dans la salle d'exposition de
l'hôtel de ville du coude donc c'est
accessible du mercredi au dimanche de
15h à 18h les autres expose son
artistique et se trouve dans le hall du
théâtre et dans le lieu culturel de la
mjc toujours à la celle saint cloud et
il ya aussi des événements ponctuels
programmée par la mairie pendant tout
cette thématique beaucoup de choses
prévues puisque c'est jusqu'au 12
décembre par exemple prochainement le 3
novembre ce sera une lecture de contes
avec l'auteur praline gay para à la
résidence renaissance sans doute aussi
d'autres occasions d'en parler mais la
semaine prochaine le 31 octobre bixente
une date que vous attendez avec
impatience et halloween est ce qu'il ya
des choses prévues peut-être on va pas
abattre tout notre cas toutes nos cartes
tout de suite grégory ça serait dommage
de ne plus rien avoir à se mettre sous
la dent la semaine prochaine mais on
peut déjà annoncer oui quelques trucs
pour vous mettre l'eau à la bouche on
commence avec nos amis les insectes
avoue qu'on commence à voir comme ça
directement les petites bestioles direct
en effet à la maison des insectes de
carrière sur scène il sera possible de
débuter son week-end d'halloween par un
petit escape game nocturne au milieu des
petites bêtes c'est le vendredi 29
octobre il ya deux créneaux 18h 19h45 je
vous lis le club suisse de l'escem guen
la grille un entomologiste de la maison
des insectes a mystérieusement disparu
depuis quelques jours mais a laissé
quelques dossiers incomplets pour mieux
comprendre et appréhender ces petites
créatures il s'agit de retrouver les
pièces manquantes ça donne envie il
faudra réserver la venturi les uns vont
réserver cette aventure c'est sur le
mail
téléphone de d'animation @ 1 5 point org
une activité à partir de 10 ans et au
tarif de 15 euros par personne à des
informations qui s'affiche pas en bas de
l'écran mais vous le disiez bixente
animations @ insectes au pluriel point
org il ya un numéro de téléphone
également pour ses réservations le 01 82
87 00 50 je le répète 01 82 87 00 50 et
on finit par une activité nocturne du
côté l'huile de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines pour jouer seul à jouer
carrément ghost rider mais ce serait
plutôt à ghost rider écolo 1 qui a
choisi de partir en trottinette
électrique ça c'est samedi 30 octobre de
18h à 19h30 la société trip in trust
organise un parcours tout terrain pour
faire un tour de l'île de loisirs il
faut déjà avoir une petite expérience de
trottinettes électriques moi je pourrais
pas le faire par exemple ce que je me
casserais à figure tout de suite le
matériel technique par contre sera
phoning fourni mais il est fortement
recommandé d'y aller déguisée du coup
bon j'ai déjà merci biche était de toute
façon on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine avec un focus spécial
halloween pour le sais tu twittes ken
programme spécial quand je vous concocte
on ne dévoile pas tout et d'ici là
alliés aussi le journal de la rédaction
qui revient est dès lundi sur tv 78 10
il a passé un très bon week end ali
coûte et et à la vision de tv 78
[Musique]